By the way I just have
to ask you really quickly.
Did you love doing Friends?
Was that so fun?
Cause that was like,
that was all so so fun.
I absolutely loved it.
I was originally supposed
to do three of 'em
and it turned into nine shows
and it's just a nice, positive,
happy place with great actors.
Well, I loved you in that
as well as so many other roles.
Okay now, tell me about this #2020 Tip Challenge,
Mr. Selleck.
I read an article in the paper
about my dear friend, Donnie,
and he left this $2,020 tip,
hoping for in the spirit
of hoping for a better 2020.
And started thinking about it
and I talked to Jillie.
I said, I guess we can afford it.
I'm going to do this
and she said,
I think you should do it.
And I go to this same restaurant most of the time
and they're like family
and everybody's hurting in New York.
It's bad.
So I wrote a little note and gave him a $2,020 tip
and knew it might get around,
but I didn't mind it in this case,
not to say I'm a magnificent human being
but to say, restaurants need help.
Even if it's $20 and 20 cents,
maybe you can help 'em out
because they're really struggling
maybe as hard hit as anything
in this city.
So.
I love everything you just said.
And this #2020 Tip Challenge,
and I love that you gave the denomination
of options for people
because everybody has something different they can give.
That is so fantastic.
Yeah.
And it has inspired us here
at the show to pay it forward
in honor of you and Donnie.
And I was wondering if you would mind joining me
in a Surprise Father-Daughter Drew Gooder.
That's what we call them around here.
They're a duo making a difference
in their community.
Would you do that with us?
I'm here, man.
(crowd applauds)
Okay, so we like surprises around here
so if it's okay,
I'm going to hide you on zoom
and then bring you back in.
Oh, there you go.
Perfect. Okay.
We'll see you in a minute, Tom Selleck.
Okay. Hello, Isabella and Luca!
Hi-
Hi Drew, Hi.
So great to meet you.
Nice to meet you.
Oh my goodness,
you're both so lovely.
You're father and daughter.
I love that you're a duo
and I see you standing inside your restaurant,
Tarallucci e Vino.
Perfect.
Thank goodness;
I really went for it.
And you guys have been working tirelessly
to support frontline workers
and what inspired you to do that?
So it was really all inspired
by an act of generosity
from a family friend of ours.
You know, we're obviously
in the restaurant business
and when the pandemic shut everything down
in New York City
and our healthcare workers, you know, were
on the front lines, battling the virus
in the hospitals,
she reached and said,
I've been reading
what's been going on in the city.
I'd love to help your guys' restaurant,
but I'd also love
for you to deliver food
to an emergency room
because she knew how hard people were working.
So on March 19th last year,
my parents actually both delivered 40 meals
to the ER doctors and nurses
at NYU Langone Hospital
on First Avenue, which is pretty close by actually.
And the reaction from the doctors
and nurses, they were so grateful.
That's what inspired us to start feed the front lines.
And I had just left college.
You know, I was kicked off campus.
I was about to graduate, but I told my friend
about the idea
and we built a website in 18 hours
and started collecting donations
and people were incredibly generous.
So that's, that's really what inspired it.
I mean, Luca, you must be so proud
of your daughter.
I could not have asked
for a better daughter.
She's amazing.
And we have delivered over 170,000 meals
but we brought on other restaurants,
restaurants from all over New York
and we've had over 35 restaurant partners.
So it was not about Tarallucci e Vino,
but it was about sort of trying to keep, you know
New York restaurants alive
because as you know, it's, it's been tough.
It is still very tough.
Well you're trying to inspire people
and clearly you have.
Now, ironically
I hear someone that inspires you.
You're a Tom Selleck fan?
Yes, I am.
Great, say hello
to Mr. Tom Selleck.
(crowd applauds)
Wow!
Hi there!
Thanks for the work you're doing.
Hi.
This is incredible.
I just thought that I should introduce you.
I was Just hanging out, wanting to say Hi.
So I grew up in Italy
and I remember watching Magnum PI.
You know?
And he was the coolest guy.
Is, still is the coolest guy out there
and I think my mother was in love with him,
you know?
Oh, yeah, we all, everybody was!
And Tom Selleck, who is such an amazing human being
which is what really makes us love him,
he has this #2020 Tip Challenge.
And so on behalf of all of us here at the show
we wanted to give you
the #$2,020 tip
that Tom and Donnie Wahlberg have been initiating.
And of course, we're going to double that
because there's two of you
and then I'm going to throw in.
So we're definitely going 10,000 here
to just say thank you for everything
that you are doing.
We all wanna help
but sometimes we don't know where to go.
So I applaud you for leading the charge on this.
Thank you so much.
Stay well and prosper.
Appreciate it.
Wow. This is so generous.
Thank you both so much.
I am in awe of you.
That's all Drew; I'm outta money.
(everyone laughs)
And yet, Tom, this is inspired by you
and Donnie Wahlberg.
And Isabella and Luca,
you really are doing something incredible.
So for more information about Feed the Frontlines,
head to our website thedrewbarrymoreshow.com
to learn more and get involved yourself.
Go New York!
(crowd applauds)
Thank you.
All right, thank you Luca and Isabella.
And Tom, thank you so much
for coming on the show today.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you Drew.
Thank you so much for giving us a lifetime of such goodness
and Blue Bloods airs on Fridays ten, nine central on CBS.
(upbeat music)